[Musik]
christian jott jenny ist entertainer
tenor und gründer des jazzfestivals
sankt moritz und seit eineinhalb jahren
ist er nun auch gemeindepräsident des
nobelort im engadin
damit sorgt er für viel unruhe und
bringt die gewohnten politischen
prozesse gehörig durcheinander
gewählt wird und somit hat es einige
bild von der welt wo man hat soviel ich
der biz antiquiert ist so durcheinander
bringt dann ist das problem oder
definitiv die andere hand und
stimmbürger sankt moritz könne ist
besser versprach im wahlkampf kann er
sein versprechen einlösen
[Musik]
richtig spannend ist das aber noch nicht
gut sehen wir jetzt sehr stutzig gemacht
natur besonders richtig lieber christian
erklärte er schaut wo sich die spur
leber christian liebe sie hier die
resultate vom zweiten wahlgang christian
800 4 1-siege 822 gratulieren richten
heißt das was gott dienen
was brächte so muss man aber ihrer
kirche dezember 2009 10 ein knappes jahr
nach seiner wahl
christian jott jenny vor einer ersten
bewährungsprobe
der entertainer leitete seine erste
gemeindeversammlung
lewis auch moritz i really besitze ich
möchte sie im namen von klein vorstand
und des gemeinderates herzlich zur
heutigen gemeindeversammlung begrüßen
glauben sie mir ich bin gleich nervös
wie vor eine premiere vielleicht sogar
noch länger
das aber so gutzeit ohne die füße
premiere rasch panik gibt es keine
leistung aber bitte verzeihen sie mir
ich würde dir zum ersten mal sind die
versuche demütig und schlank und so rund
wie möglich gestalten
bitte ich bin da sie sich kurz fassen
sie schon kontakte behörde nicht dass in
betrieb seien die kunden was unsere
vorstellung trennte offensichtlich
völlig normal frieden mit verstössen
mafiosi sind zumindestens kriegen gut
punkt mir im leben ins heutige protokoll
auf und ich möchte kurz das lineal
türkei-gp ko mini wenigkeit präsident
oder geht mit mini wenigkeit sind vor
zwei wochen beginnen die haie sie an
orte die sache im detail erklärt also
das ist nicht so dass wieder untätig
werden
ja das typische
das café mal wenigstens stars und so
stand senkrecht denken er bringt sehr
viel frische windel zusammen das am 1
ich denke als skeptiker fahren zu
begehen und ich da verletzte sich sehr
gut in szene durchsucht schlossen ja das
weltoffene und dass ich fürs sf jenes
alltag findet nun im gemeindehaus statt
hier geht's zum aktenstudium politische
knochenarbeit sitzungen und das führen
der verwaltung mit 300 mitarbeitern
besprechung mit dem schiff des
steueramts und neue klasse da bis bis
zehnte stufe und dann geben wir
englische vermarktung ok bald nach
amtsantritt wurde der vorwurf laut die
politische knochenarbeit sei nicht jenes
sache details interessierten ihn nicht
es fehle ihm in vielen dossiers das know
how
ich habe ganz klar die ich bestimmt
darum im jahr geändert und ich mag kein
mikro management sozialer nicht immer
zeit das interessiert mich das hat man
ja erstmal ein rechtsgeschäft zum
beispiel cilic die käufer genau was ihr
wollt meistens mitten in st moritz steht
ein bekanntes baufälliges haus
es gehört adolf hämmerli der in der
gemeindeversammlung protestierte
apple behauptet der boden unter seinem
haus sei 30 zentimeter abgesunken
seit die gemeinde gegenüber ein parkhaus
gebaut habe seither hat sich der
86-jährige in einem kafkaesken
rechtsstreit hineingesteigert solche
fälle will der neue gemeindepräsident
nicht vom bürostuhl auslösen sondern im
direkten gespräch
die augen die antwort sich ziehen da
sind ja zwei bis drei briefe pro buch
polizistin traf
wenn sie zur einhaltung der gesetze und
verfassungen stellt sie den stoff und
wie schön es hier gut demokrat aber
dürfte fall ist eine 40 oder 50 jahre
alt 3 ich habe aber auch gesagt ich habe
sympathie für diese branche und und ich
möchte ihm herr hubble das problem wenn
er hat ja und ich bin auch sehr dürft
voll überzeugt dass als problemlöser
dass man gerade ein ganz großes neues
hutmacher will ich glaube ja dass der
herr vor dem problem lacht und groß wird
und das hat die komponente im streitfall
kommt dir nie auch nicht weiter aber den
draht zu seinen bürgern hat er die alte
reithalle in sankt moritz ist
einsturzgefährdet
es fehlt das geld für eine renovation
seit jahren steht sie leer
doch das ist passé
dies fördere die gebäude diese situation
[Applaus]
der gemeindepräsident organisiert war
ich selbst die erste veranstaltung und
vermarktet sie in einem eigenen video
[Applaus]
präsident reports hat moritz vom ersten
august 2009 10 728 geburtstag mutter
helvetia aber eine wunderbare
traditionelle ordner über hundertjährige
tradition extra aufgemacht haben für die
hütte
geburtstag von mutter helvetia
damit löst er mit viel brimborium ein
erstes wahlversprechen ein
obwohl es immer hieß das gehe nicht
ich muss also mich der vorstand muss die
politische verantwortung
das ist ganz klar also wenn das töten
katastrophe geht ja dann seh mir tut
eigentlich aber es gibt immer
verschiedene möglichkeit dass auch trotz
neuer sage es gab vielleicht nur zwei
oder bucher straße des ganzes jahr
aber man findet einfach immer lücken
ich sage immer dass es ganz gewaltig es
nahe schien
dieser sieht dann machen wir falsch und
ich habe gemerkt dass es viele aber es
gibt durchaus in der lage wäre damals ja
auch sagen ja aber auf haben wir ein
zeitlos ich bin verantwortlich für das
gern so machen findet man einen werkraum
nur dass der durchwegs hatten viele
nicht gut bis zwei anderen und bis zum
modell den grund
wenn dies heute den extravagant war
christian besen also das war einfach ein
umwerfender erster august und mehrere
extravagant ich bin jetzt bald vier
sitze gerade jetzt nichts wiedergeboren
durch person ist der stall in der nähe
leben
ein glücklicher zufall will es dass im
jenisch ersten amtsjahr eine 100
millionen schwere indische hochzeit für
aufregung sorgt der reichste in der muk
shabani veranstaltet ein prima ding für
seinen sohn
der gigantismus spaltet die bevölkerung
einerseits ist sankt moritz weltweit in
den schlagzeilen
am bereits laufen anwohner sturm gegen
das spektakel denn sie haben nichts vom
rein privaten fest außer halle und kiel
die direkt vor ihren wohnungen in
persönlichen gesprächen kann jene die
situation entschärfen hat jetzt kann
erklärt von denen habe ich brauche dass
man es kurz die briefing wochen
miteinander dass marie zukunft einfacher
früheren damit ein anderes der
gemeindepräsident will mit einer schar
schulkinder mit glocken und peitschen
dem sogenannten charts und zug zum
brautpaar sankt moritz soll ein ort für
superreiche seien aber nicht abgeschirmt
vom alltag der einwohner
es gilt überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
schließlich gelingt es ihr nie ins
innere des festzelts zu gelangen und dem
brautpaar die offiziellen wünsche von
sankt moritz zu überbringen
[Musik]
zu guter letzt verhandelt jenny dass die
bi für die ganze sankt moritz
bevölkerung geöffnet wird
humorvoll klage und die hat das eine
großartige idee gefunden und bin ich uns
gefunden haben bestimmte buch wird oder
nicht kalt wenn der gemeindepräsident im
engadin und auch andernorts mit seiner
show auf tournee ist bat er solche
erfahrungen schoss ein
sms wird zum gut vater und manager
tanner kontakte in der branche und at&t
karotte ich schlage man zu wenig am
albanifest den winter music ninja man
barnimer stehen ließ und ich habe
jeglichen alters nicht ahnen dass ganz
klar dass alles sehr seriös abrufe im
nachhinein kann ich jetzt tue was
emotionen bedeuten
im alten umgebauten olympiastadion von
sankt moritz wohnt ja nie der zürcher
wenn er im engadin ist nach eigenen
angaben zu etwas mehr als zwei drittel
seiner zeit das gemeindepräsidium ist
mit rund einer viertel million übrig
bezahlt im wahlkampf sagte häni das sei
aber kein grund für seine kandidatur
ich finde also machen sich also ich
finde das auffällige und so was ich
übrigens als erster stelle dass ihr lohn
kürzt das haben wir absolut nach
interpret ich sagen renate hakelig
gremien tyler institutionen spenden
kommt kürzten die kollegen im
gemeindevorstand dem neuen mitglied den
lohn um 50000 franken
[Musik]
der ball kam gut an
die im gegenzug verhandelte juni das
sein pensum auf 90 prozent reduziert
wird so kann er seine künstlerischen
aktivitäten rechtfertigen
also kein voller einsatz für sankt
moritz
das schließe auch den beruf starten
ich halte eine band die frage bleibt ist
jene der richtige für das amt zweifel
äußerte nach enge freunde schon vor dem
amtsantritt politik wird in sehr
zermürbend
und er glaubt geht so es gleich und sich
einfach obwohl er an versicherern
beamten ist jede politik ist es einfach
sehr oft so man muss so viel kompromiss
liga das war kein richtig kurz pures
produkt das bringt und da muss man ganz
speziell gebaut sie anders machen und
bharat sie der ganze kontroverse und
eben abschnitts mache und er glaubt das
führt im net liga der gemeindepräsident
schaltet seinen freund corona bedingt
aus rom zu fox ist der besitzer des
olympiastadions und jenes wg partner und
natürlich an erklärt und da irgendwie
nach überwiegend irrtum sehr froh wie
christian heller setzt so gut ohne
irgendwie ihren kompromiss schließe mit
dem charakter und seine art ist das gang
und auch hier skeptiker von damals
es muss nicht immer so laufen kann hsbc
flüssiger spitz wie freier laufe in
dieser art und weise erfüllt christian
jott jenny sein präsidium in der tat die
gäste lieben liebe sankt moritz liebe
sankt moritz in der liebe eine heimliche
liebe erlebt
derzeit beim fahren mit lustig war
da verstehen sie mich nicht falsch der
blick zurück hat auch hier in st moritz
immer wieder seine existenzberechtigung
wichtigkeit und das einzigartige bauen
und fahne genau
erstmals überhaupt fraktion dass die
protokollarische tradition aufrecht la
perla die hat nun je so klappt wie jetzt
der weibel wird wieder das war aber nie
gesetzt die frauen die die fahne der die
edf locker ich wieder im wind die wird
benutzt man nutzt derweil dass man hat
und das ist schön sie verkehren
ich habe immer gesagt ich auch gerne so
dirr die trockene traditionen die
amtliche traditionen finde ich eine
pistole und drucker nutzen
damals hinter irgendeiner zwinkerte
aufmacht ist das so gut wie sicher
wieder sehr nationalistisch und das muss
ich sie und jetzt runter grad warm was
es bedeutet und was dahintersteckt vorne
dahin die präsidentin report nämlich
dafür die fürs neue jahr der herr 20
strafanzeigen staatsanwaltschaft
graubünden auch sich zucker wegen fahren
mit mit vorne
das finde ich sehr interessant die
jahrelang aber da muss auch staatsanwalt
zur grünen des jahres was machen
doch nicht alle finden das lustig aus
dem gemeindevorstand gelangte ein
internes mail an die presse
darin machen die kollegen aus der
exekutive jene schwere vorwürfe sie
verlangen von ihm mehr präsenz eine
straffere führung bund bessere dossier
kenntnisse
sonst müsse man vielleicht seine
aufgaben neu verteilen
mario salis war früh skeptisch gegenüber
yenice kandidatur und doch konnte ihn
dazu bringen an einer seiner premieren
eine einlage zum besten zu geben
[Musik]
doch in der sache bleibt service hart
dass ich gerne ähnliches haben eben
gesagt dass ich das kann
das macht er kann man die werde erkannt
luther so erholen aber aber
also wäre es wichtig eine politische
führung kritischen töne kassen sind
informant sie sind zu wenig auf manche
sind die da sprach barren durfte bau dir
aufgabe bereich wo sie handwerk nur
pflichtbewusst dafür dass ich mindestens
das was ihre kollegen e mail diskutiert
hand ich bin für ihre 20 stunden sprach
bei ich bin besser erreichbar als alle
anderen fachlichen rat bühne das sollte
so ich bin jetzt mal das präsidium ich
dass wir bei uns so gestalten dass für
mich funktioniert
[Musik]
dies lohne
bis do das ist einfach verschwunden
[Musik]